committee on standards joins us as you
can see hi uh chris thanks very much for
joining us on the program good morning
this morning uh we're moving on now says
the government uh they need to start to
help people more with the cost of living
crisis that's exactly what they're going
to do
well they certainly should be doing that
because if you look at the average
family in the rom though my my
constitution said that they've lost 2
500 pounds
a year and there's they can't see any
means of making that up and
that's
you know universal credit being cut and
the significant increase in cost of
living and but just to go back to the
events of yesterday steve barclay just
said that everything's changed at
downing street well the one thing that
hasn't changed is the prime minister um
and
he walked past these events he attended
these events he raised the glass at them
and he knew that they were happening
and and i should make a ver this may
sound like a very um pedantic point but
the rules don't say anywhere about work
events an exemption for work events
they simply said no gatherings were
allowed and these were gatherings and he
was at them so he knew they happened and
indeed you can see throughout sue gray's
reports that and quite frequently she
refers to
the the obvious fact that a lot of the
people who are attending these events
knew that they were breaking the rules
they knew that these gatherings were
breaking the rules that's why they had
to say i think we've got away with it
and you know the stories about vomit on
the carpet and um red wine stains up the
wall and the cleaners having to clean
this up
the most i think the most pernicious bit
about
um the way that
the cleaners and the security staff were
treated is these will be the people on
the lowest salaries in danny street
these will be the people who did abide
by the rules
and and that's precisely the problem
that there were there is a set of people
in downey street and they're all still
there or nearly all of them are still
there
who simply believe that the rules don't
apply to them there's one set of rules
for everybody else in it and there's one
set of rules for them and it even
existed within downing it street itself
so all the special advisers and the
senior people were able to carry on as
they wanted um but
when the cleaners and the um security
staff said look this is just not right
you're not abiding by the rules uh they
were you know they were told where to
get off that's it's just morally
indefensible i think yeah the prime
minister has addressed that we're told
by steve barclay and he is apologizing
personally to all of those involved let
me ask you let me move on because we
don't know but sorry but he isn't sorry
kay he says that he is
well he he may sort of do that apology
that sort of he did in the house of
commons yesterday but it actually
amounts to excuse after excuse after
excuse he doesn't believe he did
anything wrong or that anybody else did
he's blind to his own failings
he says we're told that he has
apologized to some staff personally and
he will apologize to more staff today
when they come on to their shift pattern
so you know we we have to accept that
that is is what the prime minister has
said and that's what he has done and
will be doing um you're the chair of the
house of commons uh committee on
standards you've recruit
recused there you go yourself you're
having difficulty this morning with
words okay
you couldn't say frankly
yeah it would appear so but you've
recused yourself from um that
investigation but procedurally you will
know what happened so talk us through
the investigation what happens
uh so the i i also chair the privileges
committee which has seven members on it
it's four conservative members two
labour and one smp
um the committee has to decide whether
the prime minister has lied to
parliament has misled parliament
instead it's not whether he has
deliberately uh it's whether he has
knowingly misled parliament it's an
important difference because if you
think of admiral nelson um you know who
put his blood his spy glass up to his
blind eye um and said what ships i see
no ships he was lying he was knowingly
lying um and i think that that may be
the conclusion that the privileges
committee comes to but i'm not sitting
on it um as you say i've recused myself
and what the committee will have to do
is we'll have to decide what evidence to
gather whether to call people in to give
evidence they could if they wanted to um
ask some of the cleaners and the
security staff for their evidence could
ask other members of staff working down
the street for their evidence
could require all the email exchanges
about uh following on from when the
prime minister spoke to the pilot to
parliament the first time about the
issue and uh to see what um and minutes
of meetings that were held to discuss um
all of this um and at some point no
doubt they would ask the prime minister
to give evidence either in in in person
or in writing and then they publish a
report which then goes to the house of
commons
it should take i would guess
i'm really guessing here but
when the standards committee had to do a
uh review a case that had been sent to
us uh about the prime minister's holiday
mystique a couple of years ago
uh from the moment that we got the
memorandum when the investigation had
already been done to completing it took
four months wow
so it'll be a while yeah if the
committee finds that um he did mislead
parliament he doesn't have to resign
though does he
uh no well if the committee it depends
what the committee recommends the
committee could recommend that
um he be suspended from the house
for a day or for ten days if it's for
ten days or more um and the house agrees
to that suspension then he could face a
a recall election and his own
constituency of 10 of his voters think
um that there should be a by-election um
so all sorts of things are possible and
and i can't entirely prejudge it because
i'm not going to be on the committee um
because i mean i
i believe that the prime minister has
lied i think he's lied repeatedly he's
done so knowingly uh sometimes he
deliberately chose not to know the facts
he didn't investigate enough the facts
enough but he was actually at the
gatherings
so he knew that they had happened but he
told parliament that they hadn't okay
well he said that he thought they were
work events and that will take us back
to the absolutely a few moments ago so
we won't go back to that what we will do
though is talk about if there's nothing
to force boris johnson johnson to quit
then what's the point of the
investigation
well they can force him to quit
if if he's i i'm sure i'm absolutely
certain that if the
privileges committee decides that the
prime minister has mislead parliament
and sends a report to the house of that
effect boris johnson may still try to
cling on but i would have thought that
at that point every self-respecting
member of the house of commons would
vote for whatever suspension is
recommended by the committee and if he's
suspended from the house he's out
that's it yeah but you need you need
conservative mps to vote for that don't
you
well
at every stage look there are four
conservative members on the privileges
committee and i respect them i i have
absolutely no questions about them one
what they will all want to do
a very proper job i i know them
individually alberto um bernard uh andy
and laura and i'm sure that they will do
a very very thorough job alongside
whichever labour mp replaces me and alan
doran's and if that committee comes to a
conclusion which has a conservative
majority on it if it comes to a
conclusion that the prime minister has
lied to parliament
i'm absolutely certain that the
parliament that the prime minister will
leave office and probably leave
parliament
but it's down to at the end of the day
it's down to those tory back benches
that we often talk about isn't it well
in the first place it's down to the
committee yes look there's a big gift at
the beginning of all of this yes i
accept that and normally when you say to
me uh mr bryant if such and such were
going to happen what would you say and
then i normally say well i don't i'll
say hypothetical questions so um i throw
it back to you i'm this is hypothetical
if but but
nonetheless hypothetically if the
committee decides that he has misled
people and misled parliament then i
think he'd be gone but more importantly
i suppose um
i think there's quite a lot of people in
the labour party who have now decided
that um actually
um for the labor party and for the next
general election let's keep boris
johnson
um
i think a lot of voters in the country
have made their mind up about the
conservative conservative party that
keeps boris johnson um you know the
culprit and the liar as their leader and
and indeed two conservatives i bumped
into in the left yesterday on the way to
a vote they they said to me look we've
lost the last the next general election
because tory colleagues won't act
against him even though they've seen it
flames of fight staff
so but the downside is it's bad for
britain because we've got two major
crises going on ukraine and the cost of
living crisis and the prime minister
isn't able to concentrate on either of
them properly because this is going to
go on and on and on and all of these
were unforced errors which stem from his
personality
they'll all happen again that mimicking
of my accent was a mile off by the way
i didn't know you had an accent okay
it's lovely to talk to you as always
we'll see you soon thank you